[音楽]
青木サの人生経営哲学100回聞いたら
豊かになる話青木サの人生経営哲学100
回聞いたら豊かになる話え今回はですね
人材の採用について是非お聞かせいただき
たいなと思ってるんですけれども採用し
ない方が良い社員のポイントというものが
つうんありましたら教えていただけますか
[音楽]
うんまこれ非常にシンプルなんだけど根が
はダメねもう否定的ものの考え方をする
人間は絶対左用しちゃだめですもう
ポジティブであることあとね頑固物はダメ
素直で向上心がある人を選ぶことあとは
怠け者はダメですやっぱり勤勉であること
でもっとあえて言うなら身内を大事にし
ないやつはだめね親高校で家族大事にする
人は
オッケーそれからあえて言うならま自分の
人生に対して責任を持てる人間はオッケー
だけど人のせいにしたりなんだろううん
自己正当化の人間は採用しないま非常に
明確ま上げてけばねまだ色々あるんだけど
この辺はねあのあえて3つって言われた
けど5つ言ってしまったけどでも参考に
なると思いますありがとうございますこの
5つに当てはまる人かどうかっていうのは
どど質問すわかるんですかいろんなこと
質問するまるまるさん人生の目的は今
どんなことを目的に頑張ってんですかとか
ままさんにとって1番大切なことって
どんなことですかとか過去自分自身どんな
こと成し遂げたのかちょっと話をしてみて
くださいと自分が1番大事にしてることや
自分がこれから将来どういう人間になって
いきたいのか
ところで先週1週間でどんな本を読みまし
たもう全部行動にしし点当てた質問して
いったら当然答えるでしょそれが言ってる
こととやってることの一貫性があれば信用
できる言ってることとやってることに一貫
性がなきゃダメなやつもう非常に明解です
で私は本音本心本気自分がもうそのまんま
行くのでそのまんま行く人間はスパンって
繋がるんですよでもその時に理想的な回答
しようとする人間は僕の質問に真正面から
答えられないですよ目がキョロキョロと
泳いだりそれからなんか言葉の中に響きが
なくなったりまずるい人間とか不誠実な
人間も論外ですけどでもそれ見破るの
難しいよね人間は弱いんですよ弱いと実は
悪くなるん
です強い人間は自尊心があるから自分を
大事にするので約束も守るしプライドで
成し遂げていきますやっぱりプライドの
ある人間を採用しなきゃだめだねうん私は
やっぱり自分を愛するようにあなたの隣人
を愛せよというバイブルのね言葉やっぱり
自分を大切にしてる人間人を大切にする
人間人柄重視ですね採用のポイントは能力
重視じゃないんですよ能力当たり前なんだ
もんそうでしょ大事なのは人柄ですよ
ありがとうございますネガティブかどう
かってどうやって見極めていくんです
[音楽]
かま例えばねままさん今自分自身ねあの
いろんな人生でねコントロールできない
こととか色々あると思うんですけどま
例えば何々のような問題に直面した時にご
自身はどんな風に対処すると思いますとか
いろんな質問を長けるで私は元々セルス
マン出身なので質問義法がめちゃ得意なの
よだそう質問を効果的に投げかけるによっ
てその反応と目の動きと声の響きとやっぱ
表情を見て判断しますそれはトレーニング
を増していくバカずだろう
なバカずだよ経験だようんで僕ね実は弱い
のはね北海道出身とね選択理論に出会って
人生変わったっていう人とねもうクリス
チャンってのは弱いんだよ俺もだめだこれ
はどうもねフィルターが入っちゃうんだよ
ね北海道と同居だとかさなんかそういう
こう共感資本もうそれ全然採用と関係ない
よねうんでもそういう弱さがも最近
なくなりましたそれでも若い時それでよく
失敗しましたあのいろんな人がいるんだよ
ねうんだから帰って肩書きはね学年通り
受け止めない方がいいやっぱりあの例えば
クリシャンでも偽物がいるんだよいや本当
だってほら色々あのね社会問題を起こし
てる変な団体とか色々あるじゃんだから
本物か偽物かっていうのは分からないから
学名でその方書きでね判断しない方がいい
のうん弱いからそういう風にすがってるの
かもしれないわけでってことは約束守れ
ない人間かもしんないんだよでもなんかさ
こうそこを信じちゃうあこの人きっといい
人なんだ思い込みこれ気をつけた方がいい
私はあまりそのそういう意味では人に対し
て素直な頃で人を見るっていうのは難しい
んだけどやっぱり素直に実装を見
るっていうの物事の実装を見るありのまま
を見るうんそれが大事だと思いますよどう
してもやっぱりその肩書きだったりとか
こんなことを成し遂げた人だよとかって
いうのが文字で先に出てしまうとなんか
もう会う前からうん男の人はすごいいい人
だって
いう思い込みしちゃうことあると思うん
ですけどなんかこの思い込みを外して真
正面からその目の前の人の素直に見
るっていうのはどうやったら
でま当然まず自分が本音本心本気で
ストレートに生きるっていうことでね最近
ねいろんな人と会っててねまずねこんな人
知ってるとかねこれろなやついないんだよ
もうね有名人の名前いっぱい出すやつって
いるわけあまり大したことないだて本当に
自分が自信持ってる人間って素ですよだ
から昔変なほら大義師でさ学歴詐称って
やつがいたじゃんバカじゃねえかなと思っ
てだから自信がないんですよいろんな人の
名前を出す人とかは自信がない人だと思っ
たり自信がない人は最後の最後で逃げる人
と思った方がいい自信がある人間っていう
のは絶対自分のプにかけて自分が温存して
でも逃げないこれが本物です俺は絶対逃げ
ない温存しても逃げない自分がかぶっても
全責任持ちますうんそれがまともな生き方
だと私は思いますけどねでもさ俺本当に
今回このYouTubeま無料で見て
もらってるんだけどめちゃ有料級の話し
てるよな俺そう思うわだから本当うちの
研修受けた受行性には繰り返し見てもらい
たいのよもうそれが同期なんだからうん
一般の人は申し訳ないけどプラスアルファ
なんですよいや本当本当本音でともかく
受行性に良くなってもらいたいの投資した
以上は元とってもらいたいんです繰り返し
何度も見て自分の思考の中にある
ネガティブなカスを全部出してもらいたい
んですよすっきりとまっすぐに自分の
求める人生を生きるそれが大事なことだと
思いますありがとうございますこの上司は
自分のことをどう思ってくれているのか
愛情それが共通効なんじゃないかなじゃあ
1人も辞めない会社かって言うとそんな
ことはない団長の思いですもっといい経営
者になろうもっと自分は力をつけようでも
おかげ様でそういう気持ちが会社を発展さ
せてきたんですよ人間だとどうしても見を
期待しちゃうんだよね青木サの人生経営
哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる
話えマネジメントについてお聞きできれば
と思うんですけれどもメンバーを達成に
導くことができる上司の共通点教えて
いただきたいと思い
[音楽]
ますこれはねまキャラクターって1人1人
違いがあるのでうんうん一概には言えない
んだけれどもまあえて言うとしたら
そこには何としてもこのメンバーを成功さ
せたいという強いこだわりがあ
るってことですよねそしてそのことが相手
にとって良いことでありその相手もその
ことを望んでいるそしてま信頼関係があっ
て上司の存在そのものを部下は信頼して
いるだからこの厳しい言葉の後ろにある
ものは愛情だとこれを受け止めている私も
ね正直個性的な経営者で個性的な上司なん
ですよある意味では不完全なところも
たくさんあるし厳しい言葉を言ったりした
ことも過去もあるし今もあると思うんだよ
ねだ
けどま少なくともうちの社員は僕のことを
うちの社長はいう厳しい言葉言ってる
けれどやっぱり叩き上げの経営者として
大切なことをすごく大切にしてきた人間だ
から社長が言うことは信頼できるとそして
それは自分のためにっていうよりも私の
ために言ってくれているあそこまで本質的
な厳しいフィードバックをしてくれて
ありがたいなって感謝の気持ちが
生まれるそういう関係なんだと思うんだよ
ねで僕は正直ね年間じゃあ1人も辞めない
会社かって言うとそんなことはないねそれ
はもう数命やっぱり離職っていうのは出る
わけですよね団長の思いです
正直辛いうんやっぱり社員可愛い
しなんでそんな勝手に可愛があるのって
言われそうなんだけどファミリーなんだよ
ね離職っていう話をくと残念だな
と俺ってまだ力ないなと幸せにできなかっ
たなって自分の自責の念相手を責めるより
も自責の念が強いうんもっといい経営者に
なろうもっと自分は力をつけようでも
おかげ様でそういう気持ちが会社を発展さ
せてきたんですよだから僕を信じて共に
歩んでる人間はみんな豊かになっているし
そしてやっぱり会社もグレードが上がって
軽団連に入ったり経済同友会経済3団体
ですよね当初の議員企業になったりまそう
やって確実に成長してきてるしま私はこれ
から数年でこの会社を次の公のステージに
あげたいという風にもまた思って
いるまでもそのプロセスの中ではやっぱり
負荷もかかるしある意味では社員になん
だろうなうん協力をさらにお願いしなけれ
ばならないこともあるかもしれないでも
それが社員のためになることでありお客様
のためになることであり社会のためになる
ことだと信じて意思決定してるからそこに
やっぱり人はついてくるんだと思うだから
同じだと思うんですよこの上司は自分の
ことをどう思ってくれているのか愛情
それが共通行なんじゃないかな深い愛情の
ある上司に人はついてくんだと思いますよ
愛情ってなんかどうやったら持てるのかな
と思ってましてやっぱりそのすごく成功さ
せてあげたいし達成させてあげたいって
上司側が思っていても実際メンバーがこう
ますごく見立だったりとかまうまくその
言ったことがやってくれなかったりとか
するとなんかがっかりしたりまむかつい
たりする気持ちって出てきてしまうのかな
て思うん
情けにはなんかどうしたらいん
[音楽]
でしょう何なんだろうねうち2等のさ芝犬
がいるんだけどめっちゃ可愛いんだよなん
でなんだろうねなんでなんだろう可愛くて
可愛くてしょうがないのよだけど1度も
喋ったこともないしンとかわけのわかん
ないなんか犬喋られるんだけどでも僕は
愛情で示していきながらでも存在自体が
愛しいわけよ愛っていうのは犬でさえが
そうじゃん見返りなんて何もないんだもん
もう毎年毛生え変わってすごいんだから
柴犬の毛はでもなんだろうそのお世話をし
ながら幸せなのよお金もかかるんだよ
こないだもうちょっと主がで来て手術した
んだけど何10万円ですよだけどちゃんと
最後までね可愛がってあげようってもう
家族みんなでやっぱ愛情を傾けてるよねだ
から見返りを期待してないんだよね存在
自体が愛しいわけですよなんで犬にも
そんな思い持てるのにじゃあ人はなぜ持て
なくなるのかって言うと期待をしすぎる
からなんです
よそして自分が予想している見返り人間だ
とどうしても見返りを期待しちゃうんだよ
ねその見返りが期待通りのことが得られ
ないと腹が立つでもそれ簡単に言うとさ
LINEを送っといて既読の時に腹立て
てるのと同じなのよあんた勝手にLINE
送ったんでしょってのはもんなんだよ
ともかく自分がしたいことをしてるそう
いう風に思って一生懸命尽くすだけ尽くし
なさいってそれは修行です
そういう心が持てるようにいつかはなり
ます私も若い時はそうはなってないのかも
しれないだけどねどうだろう僕は正直言っ
てもし脂質があるとしたら同機の純粋性だ
と思う俺だから苦手な人間ってずるい
やつあと不誠実なやつ嘘を言うやつこれ
苦手だからどんなミスしても自分の部下で
もどんな失敗してもすいませんでしたって
言ったらそれ以上責めることはしないし
それ以上追求もしない反省したら当然の
結果は本人はね経験しなきだめ朝会な朝会
とかでもやり直しも聞くし過去のことで
将来出世させないなんてこともしない僕は
人間って不完全だと思ってんだよねうんだ
から不完全なもの同士が力合わせて生き
てくのが社会でしょそういう風に思って
いくと良い関係ってできるんじゃないかな
と思うけどねなぜ僕は人のことこんなに
好きになれてるのかまもしかしたら29歳
で僕はバイブルに出会ってるので神様が僕
の中でね人を愛する心を与えてくれたん
だろうなとまそんな風に思ってますけどね
はいありがとうございますそれは甘えて
ます経営者っていうのはそういう存在なん
だよだから僕は赤字って本当にもう意味
嫌ってますよね全責任が自分にある
100%です999%ではない100%
あなたのせいです青木哲の人生経営哲学
100回聞いたら豊かになる
話今回はですね経営者は孤独っていう風に
よく言われると思うんですけれどもえ青木
社長がその孤独とまどんな風に向き合って
こられたのかそしてま孤独をこうま
サポートしてくださるいろんな相談を
できる相手っていらっしゃると思うんです
けどなんかそういう相談相手っていうのを
どうやって見つけてきたのかっていう
ところについてちょっと教えていただき
たいなと思いますうんなるほど
[音楽]
経営者は孤独じゃないと思う
よここの存在ではあるけれども孤独じゃ
ないよ俺なんかもう200人の大
ファミリーだもんもう会社に来るのが
楽しくてしょうがないよ可愛い子たちが
いっぱいいるんだもんだ僕は決してだって
学校の先生って孤独って言わないじゃん
判断力リーダーシップ能力実行
これは良い経営者に欠かせない3つの要素
ですよねで判断する時は全責任を持って
判断をするだからそういう視点からすると
依存とかね多にはできないから孤独って
言えば孤独だよね全責任でもそのそれが
好きで経営者やってるわけじゃん僕はそれ
が自分のやっぱり面白さだよねだって指揮
者だって孤独でしょ
指揮者じゃん経営者って芸術家でも全部
そうじゃんでも究極分かってもらいたいと
いう気持ち分かってもらえないっていうの
が孤独だっていう人がいるとしたらそれは
甘えてますうん経営者っていうのはそう
いう存在なんだよ孤独じゃないよじゃあ
女王蜂は孤独なのか孤独じゃないよみで1
つの価値を作り出してるわけでしょだ孤独
じゃないよねうんチームプレイだもん僕は
決して孤独だとは思わない経営者という
仕事のみならず指導者って自分の決断に
責任を持つ人という意味においては依存と
甘えは一切通用しない世界なのでそういう
意味においては古な存在やっぱり存それが
僕の傾斜イメージだよねで僕はそれを
楽しんでるしねだから3ヶ月に1回ぐらい
はそのthinkウィークていうことで
考える時間たった1人の時間を僕は取り
ますよねあえてねすごいいい仕事だと思う
よだってデザインしてそれが成就してくん
だもんそうでしょまアチーブメントといい
まうちの会社もま本当にね社員の幸せ
お客様への
貢献社会への貢献これがなんだろう全責任
を持ってそれが実現できるわけじゃない
ですかこれほどやりがいのある仕事はない
よね経営者ってねやっぱり決断業なんです
よ決断と実行なんですよだ決断力のない人
は経営者不向き
ですうんだから経営者に向いてない人間
って優柔不な人
あと知義の癖のある
人ねそれから疑心暗記疑い深いタイプこれ
は傾斜やめた方がいいこういうタイプはね
恐れにね支配されちゃいますうんそうする
とわけのわかんない占いにを頼るとかい
結構いるのよその孤独っていうあえて言う
ならその高行な存在である自分という人間
を分かってもらいたいて思う気持ちが強く
て変な占いとかわけのわからないものに
よりすがる変な進行宗教に行くとかね結構
いますよそれともう全く根拠のない成功し
てないコンサルタントにのアドバイス聞く
とかね今あのコンサルタントの倒産が今年
最大だからね俺から言わせりゃコと猿は
担当いるとだからまず自分の会社しっかり
やっててから人の会社の世話しなさいって
話じゃない僕なは絶対ありえないよね赤字
なんてのはだって高校生に経営させたって
赤字はできるよそうでしょもう前提が違う
と思うやっぱり僕は課長ですうん家でも
絶対僕は責任者です全責任を取れる覚悟と
なんだろうそこに生きがいを感じれる存在
が経者だとそんな風に思うけどねうん
ありがとうございますうん全責任を負うの
が経者だとしてももまその決断に対して
それをこうま補強してくれるアドバイザー
の方々それ必要だよその人は成功してる人
のアドバイスを聞いたらいいよあのね実
っていう言葉実行実践実力の実身だよね実
のある人の話しか聞いちゃだめなんです虚
の世界を生きてる人だから評論家とか
なんかもう全く無責任なこと言う人って
いるじゃないですか多分こうだよねうんだ
からま私はモチベーターではあるけれども
実務化でもあるうんだからできもしない
こと
をなんだろうやろうとはしないしできてる
ことをそのまま伝えてるだけなんですよ僕
はうん事実豊かになったしねどうして豊か
になれたかっつったら単純なんだよ
セールスマンになった時に誰よりも売れる
人間になるこれがまず価値じゃない勝ち
持ちになったわけだよねで自分が売れる
ようになったら今度は売らせる力を
極めようとしたわけだそれがマネージャー
でよないだからリクルーティング能力
トレーニング能力マーケティング能力ね
それからうま同行営業してフィールド
トレーニングオーダーを作る力全部それは
実現場に結果として成果としてその延長線
に役員になってその延長線で経営者になっ
てるわけだ
からだ結果を出せる力っていうのが1番
大事なんじゃないかなとあの正直ね経営者
なるのに国家資格もでもなんでもないわけ
よ俺明日から社長だって言えば誰でも社長
なれるでも継続できるかどうかは適性能力
がないと難しいうんだから適正能力のない
人の会社に働いている社員はかわいそうだ
よねうんだから僕は赤字って本当にもう
意味嫌ってますよね赤字は罪悪だっていう
考え方持ってますうんだってどうやったら
赤字になるのって教えてもらいたいぐらい
だよ逆に言うとだって単純な話が価値ある
商品を作ってそれを世の中にルフしてあと
は販売管理の管理費をちゃんと管理でき
たら利益が出て当たり前じゃないですか
うんだからなんだ読みが違うんだと思うん
だよねうんあとは最善を期待するだけの
マネージャー甘い人はやっぱり経営者は
向いてませんうんだから自己管理能力って
のがすごく問われるんだよね僕は決めた
ことは必ず実行するっていうタイプです
あとね
あの小さなことを軽く扱わ
ないうん実はあの小さなことを大切にする
人間って大きなことができるんですよだ
から大雑把っていう言葉あるけど僕結構
細かいですうん言ったことは必ず完結させ
ないと気が済まないしまそういうことの
積み重ねがやっぱり発展を作り出していく
という風に考えてますけどね
うんま甘えないってことだよああ甘えない
もう社長なんだから経営者なんだから腹
くくってことに当たるあとは全責任が自分
にある100%です99%ではない
100%あなたのせいですこういうことな
んですよ全責任を取れる
喜びここに生きるのが経営者まそういう
ことかなありがとうございますあの
ちょっと厳しめのメッセージでしたけれど
もえここで私のメッセージから得たこと
是非コメント欄によろしくお願いします
投稿してくださいあとチャンネル登録も
是非よろしくお願いし
[音楽]
ます弱い子供を敷いたげるうんとんでも
ないことです大体あの虐待っていうのが
身内から起こることが5%でしょ親に虐待
されてるんだから悲しいでもこれを根本
から解決するにはやっぱり情報伝達する
以外ないんです
よでそのことがどれほどね良くないことな
のかって気づきがあればそういうことはし
なくなりますよだそ批判するのは簡単だ
けど事前対応で教育によって社会をより
良い社会に変えていくそれが僕の今活動
ですよねうんだからなんだろう事業活動
っていうのは営理主義に何かしてるように
見えるけれどもお金というのはある意味で
その思考を実現するためのツールなんです
よだから同期前なんだよね経済的なものが
しっかりと循環しない限りその自分が
成し遂げたいことは成し遂げられないじゃ
ないですかだからちゃんとね健全な適正
利潤をもらいながらお金を循環させながら
社会にもちゃんと納税もし社員にも豊かに
しねそしてその富の循環の中から社会貢献
をしていくそれが僕は事業だと思いますよ
うん事業が本当に僕は正しい恋だと思って
いるのでうんもっと世の中に良い経営者を
増やしたいですよねうん社会が良くなり
ます国力が上がりますそうするとね隣国
からも攻め込まれることはない弱かったら
やっぱり攻め込まれちゃうんですよだ
やっぱり力って必要なんですよ財力は力
ですからうん私はすごく稼ぐ力がめちゃ
強いのであの子供たちにも良い教育を与え
たしにも留学させることができたしま家に
しても何にしてもやっぱり要塞のような家
に住むこともできてるしいや実際富ってね
愛するものを守るために必要なものなん
ですよ社員にしてもお客様に対しても僕が
もし貧乏哲学持ってたら良いもの提供でき
ないですもんそしたら喜びも小さくなる
じゃないですかやっぱ大きな喜びには
大きな祝福があるんですですようんだから
成功は
正しいこの成功は正しいという考え方の
持ち主にならなきゃだめなんですだ製品の
思想ってなんか綺麗に見えるけれども私は
政府の思想清い富の思想どんどん
チャリティをしたらいいしね豊かになって
分かっちゃえばいいじゃないですかそう
思いませんうんで生きてる間に富をを
世の中のために使えばいいんですよ貧しい
人たちのためにね里親なったっていいし何
でもできるじゃないですかでも自分がね
やっぱり貧してれ
ばなんかそういう意味では弱い立場になっ
ちゃうので僕はもう新聞少年だったから
絶対金持ちになろうと思いましたもうその
根元にあるその
パワー私よく社員にも言うんだけどネズミ
の尻尾食っても俺は生残
と絶対生き残りますよ僕だって愛するもの
守んなきゃいけないもん俺が死ぬわけに
いかないんだよだから健康管理しっかり
やってるし酒も飲まないで88まで現役
バリバリでやろうとしてるわけでしょいや
本当によく若いって言われますよ木さん
本当に年齢に見えないですねそれはそうだ
よ魂年取らないよ矢沢さんじゃないけど矢
さんもそう言ってるでしょ
年取らないよ青春とはコの要素であると
サミュエルねウルマンも言ってるじゃない
ですか僕はやっぱりね青春とは心の要素だ
と思ううんだからもうもっともっと若く
なります今学生だ
し学割かシニアかでどっちか安いを使うっ
て映画館
ね楽しく生きてかなきゃだめだよねはい
じゃ次行きましょうお金払ってもね尊敬心
って得られないんですよ努力してる人間の
その努力をちゃんと報われるようにして
あげたい人はまず変われるんですよ人を
変えることはできないんですよ青木サの
人生系哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる
話今回はですね中小企業においてま自分の
右腕だと言える幹部ナンバー2ですねをま
どう育てたらいいかということについて
是非ちょっとお話いただきたいと思います
うんうんなるほど
[音楽]
まずね自分自身がねま相手から見て
やっぱり尊敬される自分かどうかってこと
だよねだからお金払ってもね尊敬心って得
られないんですよこの人のようになりたい
とかこの人のこういうところが素晴らしい
なとかなんて言うんだろうな自分自身が
この人と共に共通の目的に向かって歩んで
ことが自分自身の人生の質を高めることが
できるし喜びにそれがつがるという風に
思ってもらえるような取り組みって大事
じゃないかなと思うんだよねま実際人の
ことは分からないので僕自身はどんな風に
してきたかって言とまず本音本心そして
本気うんあとなんだろうなやっぱり質と
それぞれ10人トなのでやっぱりこう脂質
の高い人間じゃないと高いパフォーマンス
を維持し続けることってできないのでだ
からそういう意味ではやっぱりこの人間は
物になるこの人間は物にならない例えば物
になるってどういうとこで思うかって言う
とやっぱり実行力があるかどうかってこと
だと思うんだよねまず求めてくるかどうか
求めてきてそして実行する力があって
トライアンドエラーで何度もま挑戦と挫折
これを繰り返すかもしれないでも朝鮮と
挫折を乗り越えて初めて成長があってその
先に成功があるだから僕はどんどん
チャレンジさせるタイプですよねでそんな
中で本人がどういう姿勢で仕事に取り組ん
でいるのかまシンプルに目標達成能力そこ
をやっぱよく見て誠実でね精神誠意物事に
取り組んで誠実一路思いやりがあって仲間
のことを本当に大切にしてそしてこの人の
ためなら一肌脱いでもいいと思って
もらえるような人柄を持ってる人間が
やっぱり人の上に立ってくんだと思うんだ
よそういう人間を僕は目をかけてきたうん
あの多分決定的な違いって僕は奨学金を
その取れる人間に奨学金を出すタイプなん
ですよだから怠けてる人間を働きもにする
という努力よりも努力してる人間のその
努力をちゃんと報われるようにしてあげた
いっていうことにに僕は力を注いできた
タイプだから10人いても2割に徹底的に
やっぱりこう重点的に指導していくタイプ
平等にはしないんだよねでその2割が
上がってその下の人間をサポートするだ常
に2割で8割の
成果その2割が役員に上がってきたよねだ
からまうちの会社は新卒で入で2人
取り締まり役になってる人間がいるあと
中東で1人入って今執行役になってる人間
がいるけどみんなあのうちの青きはこう
考えてるっていうその僕の大弁が
できる人間ですよねということはうちの
社長って今何考えてんだろううちの社長
って何を1番大事にしてるんだろううちの
社長は今どういうことを望んでるんだろう
かって彼らは考えてくだと思うで僕が望ん
でることは企業理念の具現化ですから上質
の追求我が者は選択利を元にした高品質の
人材教育を通して顧客の成果の想像に貢献
し全社員の物心両面の豊かさと社会の平和
と繁栄に寄与するだからその顧客の成果の
想像は価値ある商品の普及によってのみ
なされると思っているのでま僕はよく
アチーブメントピラミッドの一貫性って
いうこと言ってきてるんだ愛はスリー
プレゼンテーショントデとだから愛があれ
ば1人でも多くの人にあって熱心に説明を
するという行動で完結するはずだという
ロジックなんだよねだから僕は自分の部下
を愛す愛するということは部下を一角の
人間に育てるってことだと思うんですよで
も本人がそうなりたいと思ってなければね
例えばスポーツでもレギュラーになりたい
と思ってない人にお前どうしても
レギュラーになれっていうのは愛とは言え
ないかもしれないただ基本的には
レギュラーになりたいって確認した時に
レギュラーになりたいって普通は言うよね
じゃあレギュラーになるにはこれだけの
大下の先払いが求められるけど覚悟あるか
ってありますって言ったら分かったと
じゃあ全部プランを立てようと言って一緒
にプラン立ててあげて一緒になってその
達成を喜んできたそういう僕は上司なん
ですよねうんだからうちの幹部っていうの
はみんな僕の期待に答えてくれてる人うん
だ僕にとっては大切なものすごく大切な
存在なんですよ家族以上とは言わないけど
家族と同じぐらい大切な愛すべき存在それ
が社員ですねで特にその社員の中で幹部と
なったらそれは共通の目的に人生かけて
くれてる人と定義していいわけだから組織
の共通の目的に対してコミットメントして
人生かけてくれてるんだからそり大事にし
なきゃいけないバチ当たるじゃん僕は
じゃあ大事にするっていうことはどういう
ことかって言うと経済的にも精神的にも
豊かにできる仕組みを作って育成の過程で
部下を豊かにしてきた人生それが僕のま
人生だよねそれが今まだ200名ほどの
組織だけどまおかげ様で働きがいアワード
ベストカンパニーも9年連続入ってるしま
今準グランプリも去年も今年も第2位と
いうね100名から999ねまこれ決して
自慢話じゃなくてねまうちは全員参加型の
採用してるわけだしやっぱり社員が会社
愛してなかったら全員参加型の採用なんか
できないよね採用って人事がするものだ
なんてみんな思うじゃんうちはそうじゃ
ないもん200人全員が採用に仲間
増やそうとしてるわけだからやっぱり自分
の会社を大切に思っていたり事業の社会性
に対してコミットメントしてるからじゃ
ないかなそんな風に思うけどねうん
ありがとうございますでも実際その幹部に
なりたいかって言ってまなりたいって言う
けれどもなんか違う方向をちょっと向いて
たりとか能力が足りなかったりとかなんか
そういうことって実際にはあるんじゃない
かなとは思ってましてなんかその幹部に
なりたいって思うけれどもなんか本当に
こう幹部になってく人材ってどういう人材
でどこで見極めてるんでしょう
[音楽]
かあのね
人はまず買われるんですよ人を変えること
はできないんですよだ人は買われるんです
ねこれ大前提なんですよでそれを私は信じ
てますし能力開発の専門家として変わり
たくなるように情報を提供していくよね
真味になってあとは環境整えて
ます常にその支出かける環境を受ける本人
の選択の中でモデルになり得る良い先輩が
たくさんいる組織これが望ましい組織なん
ですよその中で自然にそこを目指してくる
人間に目をかける可愛がるでそこを伸ばし
ていくうんでそれはある意味ではエコひき
に見えるかもしれないでも僕はそれが
正しい姿だと思ったです
公平平等じゃですよ成公平なんですよだ
から努力してる人間が報われる社会努力し
てる大化を払ってる人間がちゃんと認め
られる会社そういう会社を目指すまた
作り上げていくからこそ育つんじゃないの
人がだあとは忍耐だよね早急にねもく3年
かき8年なんだからやっぱ人によって伸び
方違違うんですよ願望の強さも違うし適性
もあるしそこはやっぱり適材適所ですよね
時間をかけてでも経営者は常にやっぱり2
割の人で8割の成果なのでその2割との
コミュニケーションをやっぱり大事にし
なければいけないもう1つは全体最適の
仕組みを整え続けなきゃいけないだから
人事効果もフェアである必要あるあとま
福利構成だととかそれは全員平等です
パフォーマンス成果に対してきちっとした
評価をしてあげるまうちの場合はまね税引
語利益の3割のその利益は社員に還元する
3割は内部留保3割は配当1割は社会への
還元CSRこれを僕は2006年に考えて
ずっと実行し続けてきましたまそれが結果
的にま平均の年収も大企業に負けてない
年収も実現してるしま社員も自分の能力を
開発して会社に貢献していけば自分は
どんどんプロモーションもするしま役職が
上がればそれにふさわしい報酬が約束され
ているのでまやりがいも感じてる見通しを
持たせてあげる能力って常子の責任だと
思うんだよねでどうしたら見通し持てる
かって言ったら
がやっぱり資格化できるってことだと思う
のようんどういうことをしていったらどう
なるのかっていうことがそれをうちの場合
はもう定期的に説明会も開くし人事がもう
それを丁寧に教えてるしイントラネットの
中でねやっぱりそれがきちっと見れるよう
な仕組みもあるしやっぱりこうなんだろう
報われる組織を作るっていうことが大事な
んじゃないかなそんな風に思いますけどね
まず本人がナンバー2になりたいっていう
人間かどうかだよねナンバー2になりたく
ないっていう人間を難末になれっていう
ことをしちゃダメなのよだ僕はね多分これ
がね決定的な違いだと思う人を見て報この
人間は何を求めているのかでもっと言うと
人は自分の命を最大に輝かせたいと思っ
てるはずなので
やぱ事業目的そのものが社会性があるか
どうかまアチーブメントの場合はま社会
課題である人の不幸感から来る様々な不幸
な現象をまこの世からなくしていくことに
課題を持って教育事業やってるわけだよね
そのことにまずコミットメントしてる
そして企業理念企業ビジョンそして事業
計画それをしっかりと実行して実を作って
いけるそういう質がある人間に対し
てま公平構成に人事効果制度をしっかり
作りながら一緒になってその思考を実現
できるようにサポートしてあげることま
うちの役員はやっぱり16年17年と勤め
ていって結局そういう能力が時と共に育っ
ていったよねうんそれは2年や3年で
そんな人材育たないですだからやっぱり石
の上にも3年っていうけど基礎があって
応用があってそしてその上に育成の
マネージメントや様々な課題がこう能力
開発でそういう能力身についていくのでま
時間をかけてでもね面白いなやっぱり本人
がそうなっていくよ
ねうん自分がこうしてあげたいっていう
よりも本人のそういういうなんだろう努力
をちゃんと見てあげるってことじゃないの
あのキングダムってあるじゃないね我部真
大将軍になるぞってあれね大将軍大き将軍
はさ別に我部真に特別目かけてるわけでは
なくて我部真が一生懸命上に上がって
こようとするそれを育てていくじゃんだ
からやっぱり
中にあるのよこの人の中にあるんですよ僕
はやっぱりトップセールスなりたかった
もんだからトップセルスになったしトップ
マネージャーになりたかったもんだから
トップマネージャーになったし若い時16
時間とか働いてたからね俺それ今考えたら
ねそれが良かったかどうか分からないでも
僕は大下の先払いをして自分の能力を高め
てきたことは事実ですだから僕はなんだろ
実績というもの
で自分のポジションを作ってきたうん実績
は裏切らないよそういう人間をやっぱ
引き上げていくしかないんじゃないかな
うんやっぱり支出がうん8割かな正直だ
教育の専門の仕事してるけれども求める心
のない人間を成功させることはできないと
思います昔ね私がトで独立した直後ね
すごい著名なある成功している
コンサルタントの人に成功の秘訣を聞いた
んですよそしたらその人は成功者の
コンサルをすれば成功するっておっしゃっ
たのねでも僕はその時ピンと来なかったの
なぜかって言うと医者はね病人のために
存在してる
とだから病気の人に対してなんて医者は力
になる問題解決が仕事じゃないかでも
よくよく考えてみたら同じ医者でもそう
いう治療に焦点当てる医者もいるけれど
病気にならない体作りの指導してる医者が
いるんだよ
ねだから成功者ほど成功したいのよだから
結果的に今うちの会社がなぜ発展できた
かて言うとそのアドバイスを僕は実行した
からと思う受行性はみんな成功したくて来
てるからその成功したいという願望を
叶える具体的な技術を提供してきたから
アチーブメントは発展したわけですよ成功
したくない人を捕まえてあんた成功し
なさいと言ったこと僕はないんだよねだ
幹部も一緒じゃないかなやっぱり伸びて
くる人間を絶対その気持ちを無限にしない
必ずその思考を現実化させてあげるそこに
真心を持って取り組むてことが大事なこと
だとそんな風に思いますけどねうん
ありがとうございますはい是非ねえ今日
学んだことをえこのYouTube見て
いただいてる方はですねコメント欄に是非
ねえどうぞ記入していただきたいなと思い
ますあの投稿をね楽しみにしてますあとは
是非ねえチャンネル登録も忘れないように
お願いしますあの継続をして聞くことに
よって見ることによって必ず豊かになる
思考法が身につきますのでよろしくお願い
します人の扱い方が天才的だと言われたら
間違いなく金の苦労はないです僕は心理学
を学ぶ時代が来てると思いますよ青木里の
人生系哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる
話中小企業経営者として勉強すべきことに
ついて教えていただきたいと思いますま
中小企業経営者として成功したければこれ
だけは勉強しろというものがまあるのか
どうかそして青木社長はそれをどんな風に
勉強してこられたのかということについて
是非ですね教えていただきたいと思います
うんこれ心髄だよ
[音楽]
ね松下孝之助さんの研究僕は長年してきた
んだけど孝之助さんはま経営者にとって
1番大切なことは何かという質問に対して
自分より優れた人間を使えるということ
ですなとそうそれだけで十分ですわとこう
お答えになってんだよねナポレオンヒルに
成功の研究を依頼したアンドリー
カーネギーは己れよりも優れたものと共に
働く技を持つものここに眠るとま母BOに
刻んだと言われてますよね僕はやっぱり人
を生かす
能力うん共に働く人をうん育成
しそして価値を想像し生きがい
やりがい働きがい
を作り出せる
能力うんやっぱり人なんですよ相手にし
てるものはお客様も人だし社員も人だしだ
から人の扱い方が天才的だと言われたら
間違いなく金のはない
ですでも人の扱い方が下手金の使い方が
下手物作りが下手これは最悪の傾斜
ですだからやっぱり僕は心理学を
学ぶ時代が来てると思いますよ自分の経験
や職人のね叩き上げの経営者は自分が育て
られたように時代が変わってもZ世代の人
に対してゼネレーションギャップがあるの
に自分が根性論で育てられたからつって
根性論で行くとそしたらもうどん引きだよ
ねうん無能だとしか見えないんですよ長
時間労働でねだから私なんか昔ま
ブリタニカという会社でセールスキャリア
を積んで長時間労働で確かに僕はタフな
肉体持って叩き上げでね営業で能力開発し
てきたですよででも僕はうちの会社9日
休みですよ経団連にも入ってるし経済同友
会当初の議員企業でもあるうちはモデル
企業を目指してるんですよ分かったんです
ある時に長時間働くことが悲しも高い
パフォーマンスを生み出さないやぱ良い
仕組み良い人材良い
商品ちゃんと社会の求めに応じて適時適切
大切なものを大切にしてしっかりと社会の
求めに応じて努力していくことが経営者と
しての責任だとま僕はやっぱり採用には
妥協がないし育成にも妥協はないし営業
マーケティングに関しても良いものを作っ
たら売るということに対してはやっぱり
情熱を持って熱意を持って取り組むしうん
こないだあのキエス出身のね
コンサルタントをやってる人とちょっと
ある食事会で話したらすごくキエスの文化
とアチーブメントの文化ってあ通じるもの
があるって言われましたよねなんだろう
やっぱり満足を追求してるのでともかく
満足を追求したいんですよもうそれだけな
んですようんだ僕のこの気持ちは全くよみ
がない純粋な気持ちですねあとやっぱり
社員可愛いもん社員を豊かにしたいよ絶対
豊かにしたいよ精神的にも経済的にもどこ
の会社でも入れる子たちがアチーブメント
を入ってきてくれたわけ
じゃん信じてトップライブって僕の
メッセージ聞い
てこの気持ちを裏切るわけにいかない
じゃんそしたら自精神が働くよね一生懸命
働くよね経営者自身のやっぱり姿勢が
変わるじゃないですか
あとはやっぱり価値ある商品を世の中に
広めるルフするそしてこの有向けの商品に
よって社会課題を解決していくそこに本気
で取り組むまこういう考え方が経営者に
とって必要だと思いますよだからやな考え
方持ってる経営者はねもうM1Dでもして
ねまともな経営者にね会社譲った方が
いいっていうぐらい俺は思っ
なぜなら社員かわいそうだもんぶっちゃけ
だって未来がないでしょ安月給で呼使われ
不満言われてうちの社員の働きが悪いから
うちは儲かんないふざけろとお前のせい
じゃねえかと全部お前のせいだよって俺
いつも言ってあげてるよあなた以外の責任
者はいませんと要はなんとの人のせいにし
ないでも最終的には僕が全責任を持つそれ
が経営者なんですよただ現場の実行責任と
異人責任は違うんだよね異人責任からは
逃れられないですよ経営者ってのはいや
もううちのね本当有料のね研修に来て
もらいたいわ本当うんそしたらね根本から
ね経営が変わるからいやマジにあのねなん
だろう儲からないのは社員のせいだという
考え方が貧乏哲学なんですこれこれ100
回聞いてもそういう考え方のし豊かません
根本的に考え方改めないと全部自分が
仕組み作ったんでしょってその仕組みの中
で働いてるのが社員ですよっ
てそういうことなんだよだから責任は経営
者にあるんですようんそういうことかなま
大体あの3日ぐらいかかるんでこれ話し
出すとこのぐらいにしときたいと思い
ますそしたら5つですね1つは採用と育成
採用する能力と育成する能力それから営業
とマーケティング能力そのうちはすごい
営業力もあるんですけどマーケティング力
っていうのは実はこれが5つの中の商品力
に関係してるんですよ商品力が高ければ
高いほど営業よりも
マーケティングつまり告知することによっ
てお客さん集まってきますよねでも最終的
にはっ営業とマーケティング両方必要なん
ですよねでも本当にいい商品を持てば営業
はカバーされますうんあとは財務管理
能力それから新規事業開発能力1つの仕事
で
ずっと永続的に稼ぎ続けることって難しい
ですが時代の変化がと共にトヨタでも昔は
トヨタ防石からトヨタ自動車に変わった
ようにやっぱりですから社会のこの変化を
読み取りながら新規事業を常に育てなきゃ
だめですだM&Aも含まれるかもしれない
よね事業証券そして最後はやっぱり商品力
技術力だとううんまこの5つでもあえて
言うと本当は僕は1番大事なのは商品力
だっていう風に思ってんですよ商品力は
1番でしょうね次はやっぱり人材の採用と
育成力だと思うそしてま営業かな価値ある
商品そして営業力があるからお金の資金繰
りってほとんどしたことないぐらいもう
25年ぐらいお金の心配ない経してるわけ
でだそれはやっぱり本質にあるものはま
おそらくその商品イコールお客様満足に
対する異常な
こだわりあとはやっぱりまね新規事業の
開発それからま最終的には財務っていう
ことも当然お金をやっぱりきちっと管理し
ないとねダム経営しなきゃいけませんから
まうちもねそれないのもう資金がちゃんと
銀行にプールされている自己資本率も
70%というねまそういう系を目指し
ながらそれを本当にやりながら税引を利益
の3割は社員に還元する3割は未来のため
に内部留保するまた中に貯めるわけだよね
で3割は配当1割は社会に加減この仕組み
がねおそらくアチーブメントのもある意味
でま発展を繁栄を作り上げてきたと思い
ますこの仕組みを作るのが警察これはね
あのまさにね有料級ですこれね
YouTubeでね見れた人は最高にね
ラッキーだと思います是非ねコメント欄に
えこの学びを是非書き込んでください
そしてチャンネル登録忘れないように
よろしくお願いします
[音楽]
青木社長から見てこの人勉強熱心だなとか
この人はうまくいくなってレベルで学ん
でる人っているんですかいるよ例えば湘南
美容の相川さんあの人も16回目でしょ
今回明日から来るよねまた
必ず彼は学び続けてるよねで学んで実行し
て僕の伝えてる情報が確かだっていうこと
を確認するからさらに最熟をしてくわけだ
よだ最熟をしてく人ってのは事業が
ものすごく拡張してくよねだから果実なん
ですよあの繁栄っていうのはね自然の摂理
なんだよねだから松下孝之さんは生成発展
の法則と言ったんだけど繁栄が正しいん
です衰退は間違ってんです何か1人おりに
なっちゃってんですま50期で僕は82歳
なのでその時にどこまで行ってるかま実際
50期だと300億ぐらいか
な経常利益は60億ぐらいの会社になっ
てると思い
ます僕は82になってるわけだよねその時
でもその時にもう相談役とかっていう立場
で私
は創業者というタイトルで講演するという
のが目標なんですよそのに社員に感謝を
表しお客様に感謝を表しお取先に感謝を
表しま株主にも感謝を表しでもそれが僕は
鉄構上
から溶接こ見習い
から人生スタートして結局学習の段階指導
力開発の段階朝鮮の
段階富の形成の段階社会還元の段階
その通りになってるもんねだから本当に
あるナイチンエールの言葉人はその人が
考えている通りの人間になるこれは正しい
です間違いなく正しうんやっぱりね曖昧な
思考からは曖昧な結果しか出ないんですだ
から経営者で正直考えることを後回しに
する人は社長やめた方がいいいや本当迷惑
ですめちゃ
迷惑ちゃんと成果から逆算して毎日生き
なきゃだめだようんそうしたら成果出るん
だからうんうちの会社絶対成果を社員全員
が共有してますから毎週月曜日必ず
メッセージしてるんで僕はとみんなが
パーパスにセットアップされてで各自
それぞれが目標を設定して
で具体的なプランニングに関しては上司が
きっちり関わってプランを立ててでKPI
なんて社長が言わなくたって現場の人間
全員KPIを考えながら実行してるんだ
もんそれは赤字になりようがないでしょ
そしてやりがい生きがい働きがいをみんな
が感じてだこれが僕が作り上げていこうと
した組織体なんですよこれは今まだ200
名やそこらの組織だけどまあ500人
ぐらいまでは間違いなくこのまま維持
できると僕は思ってます採用を間違わ
なければね